the big difference between now and the
cold war was there were still adults
there were still adults in the room
willing to stand up for traditions
willing to stand up for history willing
to say that actually we have virtues as
a country and not just vices virtues as
a people not just vices things that we
did well in our history not just things
we did ill today look around the Public
Square all of the adults fled the scene
every corporation in Britain every
government Department every Publishing
House everybody sees the same thing the
people you describe as the sort of
Highly ideological students make all of
the running the shouting the desecration
of the past and the adults give in
effectively what we are living through
now in Britain and then the wider West
is a cultural revolution and it's a
cultural revolution where the adults
have been intimidated into either
silence or going along with it